so here's the first thing I've done I've
said I've introduced some pronumerals a
and X now apples a for apples why did I
let oranges be X anyone want to just
suggest a practical reason why I didn't
call them oh yeah yeah if I let them
equal dollars right and I'm about to
write you know this right if Oh with a
letter I was using how quickly do you
think my brain under pressure in an exam
is going to read that as 20 rather than
200 the answer is super fast so I'm
going to avoid that just because I know
I'm error-prone in that way so I've got
these two pronumerals and I'm going to
use them to now construct my equations
what I've got seven apples to oranges so
does your first equation look something
like that
yep with whatever letter that you used
okay good
then we've got a second one five apples
four oranges five apples four oranges
and I think it's four I was 40 so what
it's yep okay happy times now I've
written my equations at this point it's
really important that you give your
equations names a label because you're
about to get them to interact and get
them to work with each other so you
don't want to say like that equation or
the other one in this corner so just
give them names and I think most of you
are pretty comfortable calling them
things like one and two and now at this
point you want to think about the
strategies that you have at your
disposal for solving simultaneous
equations there are two primary ones and
they they're why I've chosen these
particular questions what was the
strategy that most of you chose for this
any suggestions you go ahead okay let me
write that down because it's so
important elimination is one of these
names right elimination whatever first
two is I'm going to try and eliminate
one of these pronumerals
out of the equation okay and you can do
this in a variety of ways but it looks
like probably the easiest way is to do
something simple with equation one any
suggestions yeah
yeah fantastic so it's really important
when you decided what you could do with
these equations that you actually say
what it is that you're going to do now
you don't just write some new equation
out of nowhere you've got to say where
it comes from so I'm gonna take that
first equation x 2 as suggested and that
gives me this 4x equals 8 so remember
that you're multiplying the entire
equation by by 2 so everything comes
along for the ride okay now raise your
hand if you called this next equation
equation 3 heads up about about half of
you okay interesting thank you here's
that you can call it anything you like
equation 3 is totally fine it's
certainly better than calling you
nothing I just gotta get subtle
suggestion here though rather than quite
equation 3 in this case I named this one
1/8 now why am I doing this well I
actually want to know where this
equation where was its origin like which
equation was I mucking about with to
create this one in this particular
problem that doesn't end up being that
big a deal but later on you really it
makes a difference which equation you
got things from and you want to have
something in the name rather than three
which is like where did I get three from
I don't know it was just the next thing
this name is a bit more descriptive okay
what will I do with one a what was the
point of multiplying a by two let's see
if someone else can give a suggestion
yeah I can't very good so I was trying
to eliminate out a variable a pronumeral
rather and you can see we've matched up
these four X's so if I subtract one of
these equations from the other then
things will come out in the wash should
I subtract do it should I do one a take
away two or two take away one a does it
doesn't matter in a sense it doesn't
matter but what's easier is to do it in
this order one a take away two and the
reason is because
yeah they come out with positive numbers
right I'm gonna get lots of errors and
fewer A's a bigger number take away a
smaller number it will still work out if
I did it in reverse order I just get
negatives on both sides which we know we
want to try and avoid okay so what do we
end up with how many A's will they be
left will have nine of them the exes of
course have been canceled because we
eliminated them that was the whole point
and what's the currency left over there
three or sixty very good okay so now I
can just divide through and I have the
cost of my Apple fantastic what am I
gonna do with this guy yeah I'm gonna
substitute it back in where would you
like me to substitute this back into
this particular Hey
are you happy with this one this one
does it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
just for my brains sake I think I'd
probably go hmm I think I'd probably go
here I'll show you why
here's equation two five lots of zero
dollars forty you see that that's like a
really easy thing for my brain to handle
so I'm gonna say that's plus four x
equals four dollars forty everything
else was unchanged and this is a really
easy sort of calculation to finalize
right five lots of 40 cents of course is
two dollars and then I can carry on to
the end what did you get as your final
cost for your own 60 cents now what
would you do with these two answers when
you've got these and you're finished
what would you do next
okay so I want to tie this up in a yep
tight tight up a nicely bow right I
think the nicest neatest bow would
actually be to say it well a and X would
just thinks I introduced the question
had nothing to do with those in fact
they were no perennials in it at all so
I should actually say the Apple which is
what it was really interested in right
is 40 cents and orange is whoops 60
cents okay
so you type this up in a nice neat bow
if you had a few minutes left at the end
what would you then subsequently do
after having done all the questions and
you were going back you had a look you
can totally check this right you could
substitute a back into either or both of
these equations and they should check
out which I think we're happy with
whatever that